elle est en soi palliatif c'est pour une
amie elle a un cancer ma tante avait un
cancer il faut y croire et il y a la foi
vous y avez cru salut à donner de
l'espoir
j'aimerais laisser un message pour Queen
va venir la voir je vais marcher et je
dois continuer à vivre tu as vu Harold
quand tu marches c'est pour aller à ta
voiture je dois le faire Maurine tu sais
ce que tu dois faire ça n'est jamais
qu'un petit trajet de 800 km
tu as vu les nouvelles on ne parle que
de toi les gens sont très gentils j'ai
une chambre d'amis vous pouvez rester
ici cette nuit
[Musique]
moi aussi je vais sauver kuni mon mari
ne doit pas faire cette marche il
traverse toute l'Angleterre à pied il
pourrait causer un accident
ce qu'il fait c'est beau en fait
n'importe qui peut faire ce que je fais
je veux que tu rentres à la maison tu
devais croire en Lui Maurine j'ai passé
ma vie entière à ne rien faire
et là j'agis tu comprends
tout ça dans le monde a besoin un peu
moins de raison et un peu plus de foi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]